South Africa's President Jacob Zuma
along with the government officials and
state employees who allowed Sudan's
President to leave the country did so in
contempt of a court order earlier we
spoke to two lassies where's we
similarly the senior political
correspondent for the South African TV
news channel ANCA in Johannesburg most
of us the journalists who have been on
this story were quite cynical throughout
there was no expectation from many of us
that Omar al-bashir would be arrested
during the meeting of the AU summit here
in Johannesburg because it would have
presented a huge nightmare for the South
African government for starters we
accepted that for him to come here the
must have been guarantees that he was
not going to get arrested but what it
has left behind is really a domestic
storm for the Zuma administration and
it's certainly one that strikes at the
heart of the constitutionalism and
adherence to constitutional precepts en
South Africa the argument is that the
president is in contempt of court and
the government because you remember the
court order was quite clear that the
South African government should do all
it can to make to make sure that all
personnel at points of entry and exit
alleged of this order that he cannot
leave until the meta has been dealt with
and the particular point of exit a
vertical off Air Force Base there was
confirmation from government during the
court proceedings that the order had
been communicated to officials they so
for him to have been able to leave
before the meta was finalized is proving
to be something that is raising a lot of
questions the Southern African
litigation center the group that brought
the court actions in the first place is
already in the process of instituting
legal legal action against the
government of South Africa for contempt
of court the issue of litigation is a
big thing in South African politics you
have parties such as the opposition
Democratic Alliance who have adopted the
issue of litigation against government
as a political strategy because
in their view the Zuma administration in
particular has been violating the South
African Constitution at every turn so
you we are very much used to see in this
court cases being brought so there's
been all sorts of litigation this is
just the latest in a series of cases
that have been brought by the opposition
it is certainly the opposition's
argument that the term that has actually
been used is wrecking ball that
President Jacob Zuma is a one-man
wrecking ball of all institutions of
covenants in South Africa and this will
certainly be added to the charges that
have been brought against him by the
opposition that he is destroying in the
country's institutions